stehen wir vor dem umbruch der
kosmologie kann jetzt endlich die
expansion unseres universums konsistent
erklärt werden bisher gibt es zahlreiche
verschiedene werte für die hubble
konstante die die ausdehnung des
weltraums eigentlich exakt beziffern
kann aber sie ist halt nicht exakt je
nachdem wie sie gemessen wird gibt es
unterschiedliche ergebnisse jetzt gibt
es neue erkenntnisse zu der mysteriösen
diskrepanz brauchen wir also doch keine
neue physik klicks umsatz im future
krieges dreimal pro woche spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur so verpasst ihr
nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen
der umbruch würde hier allerdings
bedeuten dass ein umbruch ausbleiben
würde dennoch rechnen viele forschende
mit einer neuen physik hinter den
unterschiedlichen ergebnissen für die
hubble konstante und das wäre hier der
umbruch wenn es diesen umbruch nicht
gäbe klingt verrückt ist aber so die
diskussion um die so genannte hubble
konstante nehmen kein ende
und je mehr messungen gemacht werden
desto mehr unterschiedliche ergebnisse
gibt es so scheint es dabei spielt sie
eine entscheidende rolle für unser
verständnis des kosmos der astronomen
edwin hubble beobachtet schon vor knapp
100 jahren 1928 dass sich andere
galaxien von uns weg bewegen und zwar
umso schneller je weiter sie von uns
entfernt sind der rückschluss daraus das
weltall selbst ist es was sich ausdehnt
das habe gesetz beschreibt also
vereinfacht gesagt wie schnell die
geschwindigkeit der galaxien mit ihrer
entfernung wächst oder anders formuliert
gibt sie an mit welcher geschwindigkeit
das universum gegenwärtig expandiert ein
objekt das sich in einer entfernung von
einem megaparsec also 3,26 millionen
lichtjahren befindet entfernt sich also
allein aufgrund der expansion des
universums mit der durch die hubble
konstante definierten geschwindigkeit
somit bildet die habe konstante nicht
weniger als die basis für unser modernes
verständnis von unseren kosmos
doch das problem die habe konstante
scheint anders als ihr name es an dort
gar nicht konstant zu sein denn alle
methoden zur messung der habe konstante
führen mehr oder weniger zu
unterschiedlichen ergebnissen je nach
messungen liegt die hubble konstante mal
bei 7
61 oder 68 mal bei 73,2 je nachdem was
man beobachtet supernovae
gravitationslinsen hintergrundstrahlung
in manchen berechnung erhält man auch
ein ergebnis das irgendwo dazwischen
liegt die habe konstante ist also
ungleich und genau das trat
forschungsteams weltweit in den wahnsinn
doch die renommierte astronomen bendit
riemen von der university of chicago
kommt in einer aktuellen studie
jetzt so ganz neuen erkenntnissen ihre
analyse erfolgte auf der basis von neu
kalibrierten distanz messungen zu
sterben in ihrer neuen studie gehen
davon aus dass der erbitterte streit in
der astronomie community um die hubble
konstante bald ein ende haben wird
fest steht die messung rund um die
hubble konstante sind alles andere als
einfach ganz anders als bei vielen
anderen naturkonstanten schließlich
basieren sie auf der entfernung andere
astronomische objekte und ihre
geschwindigkeit in bezug auf uns und
dabei handelt es sich eben um wirklich
sehr sehr weit entfernte objekte vor
zwei jahren 2009/10 war ein
internationales forschungsteam auf eine
habe konstante von 74,0 drei kilometern
pro sekunde pro megaparsec gekommen das
ist also die anzahl von kilometern pro
sekunde die die geschwindigkeit von
objekten pro entfernung in megaparsec
zunimmt ganz einfach pro megaparsec
nimmt die geschwindigkeit zug und zwar
in diesem fall um 74,0 drei kilometer
pro sekunde und das brot megaparsec mehr
entfernung und so weiter und so fort
also bei zwei megaparsec wenn zweimal 74
03 und so weiter und so fort
und das sorgte für aufruhr in der
astronomie denn dieser wert war ganze
neun prozent mehr als es das
weltraumteleskop lang ermittelt hatte
die fachleute aber waren sich sicher
dass dieses ergebnis auf basis von
distanzmessung sehr genau wahr
dieselbe methode hatten auch us
fachleute im jahr 2020 angewandt auf
diese wissenschafterinnen
wissenschaftler hatten die entfernung zu
astronomischen objekten gemessen um
deren flucht geschwindigkeit zu
erreichen konkret geht es bei diesen
distanzmessung um bestimmte sterne die
sogenannten c 4
diese sterne pulsieren zunächst muss
deren absolute ehrlichkeit ermittelt
werden womit dann in einem zweiten
schritt die entfernung ermittelt werden
kann
astronomie teams bezeichnen die
zufrieden manchmal auch als standard
kerzen das eben vor allem für
entfernungsbestimmung genutzt werden um
die habe konstante genauer zu bestimmen
man kennt halt ihre eigenschaften sehr
genau und wenn man weiß wie ein objekt
das sehr weit entfernt ist sich verhält
wie hell es zum beispiel ist dann kann
man eben die habe konstante sehr genau
ermittelt das ergebnis aber auch hier
ziemlich ähnlich die hubble konstante
könnte demnach bei 73,9 kilometern pro
sekunde pro megaparsec liegen anfang
dieses jahres dann ein neuer möglicher
wert forschende hatten mit hilfe des
teleskops in chile die kosmische
hintergrundstrahlung ermittelt gemeint
ist damit quasi das nachglühen des
urknalls also die reste des lichts die
rund 380.000 jahre nach der entstehung
des universums ausgestrahlt wurden wie
lange war dieses lichts also zur erde
unterwegs demnach könnte das universum
13,77 milliarden jahre alt seid bei
einer ungenauigkeit von 40 millionen
jahren daraus hatte das forschungsteam
dann auch die hubble konstante ermittelt
67,6 km pro sekunde megaparsec ein
ergebnis das enorm von den vorherigen
messergebnissen abweicht dafür aber
passt es sehr gut zu den bankwerten die
im jahr 2013 vorgestellt worden waren
und mit hilfe des esa weltraumteleskops
planck erfolgt waren
diese plant analysen gelten in der
fachwelt als goldstandard dennoch die
diskussion um die werte hält an was
bedeuten diese unstimmigkeiten und wie
sind sie zu interpretieren heißt dass
möglicherweise dass die beteiligten
forschungsteams bisher nicht sauber
gearbeitet haben oder auch mehr
möglicherweise eben sogar eine neue
physik
manche fachleute gehen genau davon aus
demnach ist unser bisheriges
physikalisches verständnis mangelhaft
und die darauf basierenden modelle
einfach noch nicht ausreichend somit
könnten alle messungen zur größe und zur
ausdehnung des universums stimmen die
interpretation dieser messungen dagegen
nicht eine studie aus dem jahr 2009 10
kommt zu diesem ergebnis us fachleute
hatten sich dabei das modell des
sogenannten klang horizont genauer
angeschaut demnach
haben schallwellen debug urknall durch
das vermischen von licht und materie
entstanden sind das universum zum
klingen gebracht
nach dem abkühlen der materie nach etwa
380.000 jahren stoppte das klingen denn
die schallwellen wurden abgedämpft doch
davon blieb etwas übrig und zwar ein
eingefrorenes wellenmuster im kosmischen
mikrowellenhintergrund und der klang
beziehungsweise schallow rietz und
definiert die letzten schallwellen des
musters und das forschungsteam ist sich
sicher dass diese aufgenommen klänge
konkrete ableitung zu den eigenschaften
und zusammensetzung des universums
möglich machen
doch dabei sei das bisherige modell des
klang horizonte zu korrigieren
laut des forschungsteams würden
tatsächlich alle studien stimmig sein
wenn man die größe des klang horizont
verkleinern würde
eine erklärung könnte sein dass das sehr
junge universum deutlich schneller
expandiert ist als wir es bisher
annehmen dann wäre es vereinfacht gesagt
auch schneller abgekühlt und der klang
horizont wäre früher eingefroren und
somit auch kleiner als in den bisherigen
modellen angenommen ein noch verborgenes
geheimnis unseres universums also
vielleicht sogar eine art neuer zutat im
dunklen sektor und eine solche lösung
zeichnet sich jetzt auch für die hubble
konstante ab die kanadische
wissenschaftlerin wenn die freeman hat
die habe konstante seit vielen jahren im
blick und kommt jetzt zu einer ganz
neuen erkenntnis sie geht nicht davon
aus dass eine neue physik notwendig ist
stattdessen ist sie sich sicher dass
sich die bislang ermittelten
diskrepanzen rund um die hubble
konstante in der nächsten zeit klären
werden ihre forschung basiert vor allem
auf einer neuen methode namens tipp auf
der red giant brands kurz die agb es
handelt sich um eine neu kalibrierte
distanzmessung von stern dabei geht es
um bestimmte eigenschaften von roten
riesenstern damit kommt sie auf einen
wert von 69 8 kilometern pro sekunde pro
megabyte 6 und fällt damit genau
zwischen die anderen aktuell ermittelten
werte die mit den beiden anderen
methoden ermittelt worden waren dazu
sagt die astronomen
ich wollte mir sowohl die zufrieden als
auch die roten riesen genau ansehen ich
kenne ihre stärken und schwächen gut ich
bin zu dem schluss gekommen dass wir
keine fundamentalen neue
sie brauchen ihr ergebnis also ein
deutlicher hinweis darauf dass sich die
lücke bald schließen wird so das fazit
von wendy freeman und ihrem
forschungsteam einen möglichen fehler in
bisherigen messungen sieht sie darin
dass die zufrieden sterne rauschen und
somit kompliziert zu vermessen sein
hier könnten sich möglicherweise
systematische fehler verstecken
die aber durch eine bessere datenlage
aufzudecken seien
bessere daten erhoffen sich die
fachleute unter anderem durch das
weltraumteleskop james webb das in
diesem jahr 2021 starten soll
das würde sowieso eine ganz besondere
geschichte
wenn die firmen und ihr team haben sich
dafür beobachtungszeit gesichert so
wollen sie die roten riesen und sie für
jeden noch einmal genauer vermessen denn
das james webb teleskop hat eine
unglaublich riesige auflösung viel
feiner kann sie details im weltraum
ermitteln als das hubble teleskop und
andere teleskope
wir werden also viel tiefer in den
weltraum sehen können und für die kabel
konstante könnte das wirklich
konsequenzen haben
so könnte sich die diskrepanz bezüglich
der konstante also schon bald schließen
dabei schließt die astronomen aber
keinesfalls eine neue physik aus doch
selbst wenn dies doch nicht der fall
wäre freeman protonen noch einmal
eindrücklich dass auch die bestätigung
des standardmodells der kosmologie ein
entscheidender schritt sei also der
bestätigung eines homogenen und isotopen
weltraum ist er also egal an welchem
punkt man sich befindet und egal in
welche richtung man schaut ist das
weltall ist das universum immer gleich
das gilt nicht für kleine entfernung wie
man am sternenhimmel sie aber für große
entfernung vereinfacht das universum ist
eine trübe suppe die überall gleich trüb
ist dazu wenn die freeman
es gibt noch raum für neue physik aber
selbst wenn nicht würde dies zeigen dass
das standard modell das wir haben
grundsätzlich richtig ist auch das wäre
eine tiefgreifende schlussfolgerung das
ist das interessante an der
wissenschaftlich kennen die antworten
nicht im voraus es ist eine wirklich
aufregende zeit mit dabei zu sein das
ganze ist wirklich ein riesen riesending
für die wii
mannschaft in diesem video habe ich das
noch mal genauer unter die lupe genommen
die große habe krise ist das universum
ganz anders als wir denken anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren einfach auf den
button unter jedem video klicken das ist
kostenlos und macht schlauch bis dann
bleibt dran